this episode brought to you by Stardust
fan sharing video reactions to movies TV
and trailers
[Music]
you
are you stopping the opening crawl again
whoa
critics knob what are you guys doing in
space I would just wrapped up our force
awakens review as well as just
celebrated Hannukah well I just finished
doing my robe one review with you
continuity wise I don't think those
timelines sync up pretty sure are two
separate storylines match up exactly
pretty sure yeah it only feels like two
years have gone by yeah and we all look
exactly the same as when we saw each
other a couple seconds ago
do we I'm pretty sure at least my teeth
look different yeah so step up the crawl
so we can review the last Jedi I don't
know it's literally no time has passed I
don't think the crawl is gonna give us
much look this is how these Star Wars
movies work a few years pass by with
each one and the crawl always catches us
up tonio Critic they got nothing well
we'll be the judge of that so step off
and damnit yeah I told me the crawls
pointless they got
[Music]
alright let's just get on with it oh
wait I was wondering with the last week
meow Boyd was right let's just get going
do that
Kris there have been huge advances in
the last couple of seconds since we saw
each other the for space technology
appearing wherever you want all big
breakthroughs and we have those in
genius minds to thank for it boards
they're responsible for all this what do
you think they were just a toy ad named
after Swedish Chef gibberish shame stuck
Shh the ports are the most important
part of Star Wars right now they're even
more central than the force I mean I
like him fine I didn't realize they were
so interval Venant everything they are
extremely interwove in now let them
continue to figure out the mysteries of
the universe while we start our review
man I am so sorry again pork's they'll
forgive you stuckman
in time this is our review of the last
Jedi aka a porks tail the last Jedi is
episode 8 of the Star Wars whatever gee
it was highly anticipated obviously but
also carried a lot of concern after
complaints that its predecessor force
awakens was a retread of a new hope fans
were worried whether or not this would
be a retread of Empire Strikes Back they
were also concerned it might be slightly
underwhelming like many parts of its
spin-off rogue one so this film had a
lot to live up to and several hurdles to
jump but thankfully the port's pulled us
through unlike some naysayers that
doubted I'm sorry I didn't know
shame stuck man stop let's see how left
it I did with the last Jedi shame after
an impressive space fight on par with
rogue one all that was missing was Darth
Vader sealing someone to death general
Leia escapes with the resistance
angering general Hux but especially
angering emperor ish Snoke Lord Snoke
I assure you my hammy overacting will
not be flossin next time please don't
use your voice to do this
not feeling it buddy I think you'd have
your stuff together after our planet
destroying eight I understand your
smokiness but we have a way of tracking
them through Lightspeed oh that's cool
you'd think me being so powerful I'd
sense that well maybe read the report on
your desk every once in a while no I got
apprentice to do
speaking of where's that douchebag from
girls three things don't kill your
mother got a ditch the pointless masks
gone and do a shirtless scene for the
ladies of what girls right unwillingly
girlfriend of course girlfriend kylo Ren
finds he can't destroy his mother but
luckily the other fighters Ken blasting
her into space I'd be lying if I said
this wasn't a little awkward considering
this is carrie fisher's last movie oh
don't worry
it gets even more on court oh come on
critic show what really happened that is
what really happened she goes shooting
star on our asses even if you overlook
Fisher's passing and the fact that we're
watching her cold corpse come back to
life that's a pretty big overlook what
did lay a lure to do something like that
we see how hard it is for prodigies Luke
and Rey just to move rocks
how can she vac you suck her way back to
the ship with no practice maybe Luke and
her were getting a drink one night and
he said so if by some rare chance you're
out Sandra pole looking in space just
remember hold your hand out to the
nearest ship force has got your back
it's uncomfortably specific but good to
know
welcome to my world it's weird meanwhile
Rey is still in the midst of handing
Luke Skywalker his lightsaber Master
Skywalker I've journeyed far and wide
okay Luke tries ignoring her but the big
walking carpet is a little more forceful
Chewie what are you doing here
I told you I'm not a Jedi anymore ray
brings Luke up to speed with all the
things have happened since he's been
gone so Han gave up these sequels to do
Blade Runner sequels knows a smart
choice
show me the ways of the force then you
can come back with me and restore
balance no I'm happy here
with my weird lizard nuns my green
nipple alien milk and of course the
porks my god you have posed here yes
they have taught me more about the force
than I ever thought possible okay did
they because I don't remember that
happening I can't believe you missed how
important they are listen to him not
marshmallows of Enchantment chez Luke
still says no but our two shows him his
frenching sister which gives him the
motivation to train again meanwhile
Huck's is still chasing down Leia ship
but due to some confusing techno jargon
they can't defeat them yet tell me again
why we're not firing at them they're too
out of range but they can't even go to
light speed no they'd run out of fuel
and why don't we go a little faster than
they're going look we only have three
settings on this ship do you want evil
or efficient well evil of course while
Leia is out of commission the
second-in-command vice-admiral hold
though point that would have been a
different movie is put in charge and she
seems less like an admiral and more like
a working mom trying to keep her cool
around her teenage son we need some
answers we need to know what's going on
I hear you but I need
you trust my decision ha how can we
trust you if we don't even know what
you're doing I need to keep things from
you so that you can learn a lesson we
don't need to learn any lessons what we
need to do is this brings us to Finn who
just woke up from his kinda coma and
rose a technician who lost her sister in
battle rose you know about space
engineering how are they tracking us
even though we use light speed it must
be that new pork technology that's
changing the world ow
there's a Code Breaker who can help us
we can sneak to the solar system he's at
bring him back and he can hack the other
ship great let's go you're coming um
we're good all fine thanks though are
you sure it's really exciting yeah we
yes space horses and everything
probably not as exciting as you'd expect
yeah I'm getting a sidequest filler vibe
Don't Tell whoa come on all right
let's talk about this scene Finn and
Rose are fine characters but their
subplot feels unnecessary and not very
Star Wars they go to a surprisingly
boring casino where the Code Breaker is
but a lot of the time it's just
listening to them say I was raised here
among the people abused to make the
system of greed work social commentary
social commentary social commentary
social commentary with political subtext
remember the pointless diner scene and
Attack of the Clones
and the pointless squid scene from rogue
one just combine those scenes together
and you have one fourth of your movie
what's unfortunate is that every time it
cuts back to ray and Luke the story
becomes so challenging and mythical
I knew snowcat already corrupted kylos
mind for a split second I thought about
killing us but then I was like you know
that but then he happened to wake up at
that exact moment and so yeah all of
this is kind of because of poorly timed
whites which my god
let's continue to explore this and
develop our us again we freed some
animals space horses crates
oh and we found the codebreaker but he
was busy and didn't do anything in fact
you can probably start a pointless
MacGuffin count around now awesome can
you let us get back to Luke and Rey
again oh I would the strange section of
the island be associated with the dark
side well no this should be interesting
perhaps because it could give me access
to my past and the way of the Jedi is
letting go of your past can you drag the
knob
we found another code breaker this is DJ
oh god is that what we call you yep I'm
a rogue who always plays in the winning
sis's aside is that supposed to be a
stutter yeah but it's pretty
inconsistent just like this movie am i
rotor override I'm gonna be the most
utilized cameo since Quentin and
Christie
[Music]
you
hey guys here's the best reactions to
what I just reviewed this week overall I
just I did not like this movie some of
the scenes were very pointless that
Casino part dumb Mark Hamill as Luke was
so good this is his best he's ever been
as Luke finally in between kylo Ren and
Luke Skywalker was freakin awesome I
just have no words for the film was
complete garbage that's my only thing I
have to say about this film to me this
was the Star Wars movie I needed a
change of pace you know it deepens the
mythology it makes us question things
about the world of Star Wars and I can't
wait to see what comes next
you have opinions a lot of opinions
about movies TV shows even trailers
there's so much to talk about you get
emotional about them just like anybody
gets emotional about them well now you
don't have to wait to get that raw
emotion straight to the Internet why
because we got star does app it allows
you instantly to film your reactions to
movies TV shows and even trailers happy
angry confused whatever it is and
whatever your reaction is Stardust is
there to show it some of the wildest and
craziest reactions are on there and
there's so much fun to watch there's a
lot of variety endless possibilities and
they're definitely worth checking out
I even using myself this week I gave
reactions to Fernan in the trailer from
Mamma Mia to and Christmas Story live
it's there to get the first and best
reaction that you got it's a ton of fun
and 100% free so check out other
people's opinions as well as sharing
your own also stay tuned afterwards to
see how you can be in the next nostalgia
critic
[Music]
[Applause]
ray decides to go to kylo Ren because
she feels they're still good in him
while Luke is thinking about burning
what's left of the Jedi texts he gets an
unexpected visitor though what's up dog
back off Master Yoda I'm gonna destroy
the Jedi tree Temple thingy at least I
think I'm going to let's look more
shocked whoa I completely underestimated
Jedi ghosts talk about becoming more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
that Muppet don't mess around you always
thought the Jedi spirits were more of a
guiding light giving advice and wisdom
but that kind of power you can have a
frigging Jedi ghost army like in Return
of the King and win this war in two
seconds we must let go of the past and
create a future of new challenges and
ideas you do know you're talking to Star
Wars fans right right my ass they can
fair enough back on hold oh Poe
takes over command by forcing her to
surrender this is me mr. Poe that's
right we're taking over we're finally
gonna put things the way they should be
I'm tired of listening to you I'm tired
of not giving all the answers
I'm tired of the is nobody having a
problem with me holding a gun at you
taking over the ship yeah everyone seems
fine doing their own thing yeah I can't
thought there'd be a lot more resistance
in this resistance
general yeah well done hold oh you got
us to the planet where we can evacuate
our foods right so this was all part of
your plan yeah
well why did you just tell us before
well like I said before to teach you a
lesson what not telling anyone the plan
of risking a mutiny that literally just
happened well was it gibberish yeah that
was an alien language what does it mean
I mean shut up Ren takes rate of smoke
and what is up with that Playboy Mansion
rope yes no keys looking less like an
intimidating villain and more like a
crumpled-up drawing a quagmire ray baby
welcome to my pad
do you like my smoking jacket I am
totally gonna rule the universe
granted the CGT autumn is a lot better
than in the last one but some of this
material is a little too on-the-nose
familiar let me show you your friends as
they perish in space let me loosen your
cuffs because that's proven to be smart
in the past
let me make this a little easier page 84
scene 5 where you reveal there's no more
good left in your apprentice yeah page
92 scene 7 where you reveal that you've
tricked me and you're more powerful than
me got it at page 103 scene
12 well you reveal you're going to kill
me but then your apprentice stabs you in
the back right on it but we skip those
[Music]
who the hell even was I would it have
killed anyone to give me one sentence of
backstory
[Music]
second time we let the leader of the
dark side get killed we're gonna fake
the red guards are cursed
it's okay Harry revenge is afoot right
seven every start sure but you got Harry
what are you doing I'm going for Becca
no Harry we got this I really feel like
we don't you think more cards would have
saved our Emperor very much yeah no we
use our ninja moves with no blasters
sounds very wrong it feels so right I
think this is why we have two Emperor's
on our dead list Harry were the red guys
when has anything ever gone bad for a
guy wearing red and sci-fi right Josh
[Music]
come with me together we can page 92
scene 4 of Empire Strikes Back
well that is my favorite page but I
can't I know my parents were a bunch of
nobodies who abandoned me I was sure
what that has to do is wait what hang on
if her parents are nobody why was the
last movie building it up like they were
somebody MacGuffin number two oh what a
twist
I guess speaking of weird surprises
after its reveal the DJ switched sides
Jinja traitor make the gothic number
three bb-8 saves the day by coming down
everyone operating a killer robot
bb-8 weirdly has a body count the spin
and phasma have a big fight that's been
building up for a while time to finish
what we sort of started unfortunately
it's cut short because hold o sacrifices
herself by aiming her abandoned ship at
the first order and putting it in
Lightspeed
hey guys my last words crazy right
sorry we had to cut it short what for
boring casino fillers MacGuffin number
four mean real surprises in this eight
lines kylo Ren unconscious and tries to
finish him off it's the end of the line
for you got something right there let me
show it just just then oh honey control
off let's go destroy the resistance on
the planet below the resistance are
cheerfully reunited there I hugged him
you happy you weirdos and Greedo shot
first Oh
doesn't last long as the first order
sends in the 8080 walkers isn't it
pronounced a tactic it's gonna be enough
in the comments why worry now
oh no the laser battering ram Oh what
now it's exactly what it sounds like I'm
gonna sacrifice myself to it yeah I
guess it did kind of explain itself Finn
tries to sacrifice himself to destroy
the laser but Rose stops him at the last
minute rules why'd you do it Rose it's
not about fighting the things we hate
it's about saving the things we love so
you sacrificed yourself to stop him from
sacrificing himself yeah either way
someone's getting sacrificed okay save
the things we love but now take my
middle school kids um is that the kind
of relationship we had cuz honestly I
think I had more chemistry with Pope hey
thanks a lot buddy now bring her back
and be sure to keep it vague whether or
not she's dead we don't know if she's
sequel material yet Hey oh come on
you're set for life with conventions
Luke Skywalker arrived
though and sees his sister one last time
before facing kylo Ren allowing the
resistance time to escape don't even
trying Tori Skywalker I can see right
through you Oh kylo Ren I have come to
apologize for failing you know that even
if you were to blow me to smithereens
you would only increase the pain that
you feel
look operation blow him to smithereens
with a smashing success you can even ask
him yourself it turns out Luke has used
all of his powers to project himself
from entire planets away ha ha ha ha ha
you think this is the real quid but it
drains all of his literal lifeforce he
strikes at captain Morgan's pose and
fades into the sunsets allowing Wray to
rescue the resistance while he distracts
them this will likely be polarizing for
some fans but here's a few reasons why I
don't mind it it shows that both Luke
and the force are continuing to change
and evolve that's what we want from our
myths isn't it to evolve what if after a
new hope fans said the force can't shoot
lightning or the force can't make you
see ghosts or the force can't lift an
entire ship we would miss out on an ever
developing and ever-changing world that
was being shaped and molded so in my
opinion this is a great and even
practical addition to what the force can
do yeah but he was projecting the dice
the whole time - what while he's
fighting from galaxies away killing
what's left of him was he really just
sitting on that rock saying to himself
remember the dice remember the dice
remember the dice remember the dice that
just seems like a weird detail he would
focus on snob who do you think taught
him how to do that my god question the
poor's and brought shame to all oh that
is not the pork way oh it is okay
continue no no no no you know one's died
enough fine
finally we see one of the abused kids
from the casino look out into the Stars
imagining all that the future holds for
him and yes he even appears to be force
sensitive
last Jedi my ass this movie should have
been called gotcha
it's like totally gonna be bored Jedi
and that was the latest Star Wars movie
how was it amazing
except what it was kind of dumb the more
I think back to it the more I do find
things wrong with it
but at the same time the more I think
back to it the more I don't care because
I'm so distracted by how visually grand
and emotionally breathtaking the other
scenes are it has flaws
certainly and for some they might be too
distracting but it still feels like Star
Wars even though it's not going in a
completely different direction it's
still going in a direction that's
different enough to be entertaining it
borrows from more than just from itself
that borrows from classic myths anime
religions and philosophies it still
knows how to keep us talking and asking
questions looking for deeper meanings
which is what any timeless myth should
do and I'm still looking forward to
seeing what's gonna happen next in a
galaxy far far away
and after all this I just gotta say
thank you porks for making this all
blossom okay seriously I did not like
those things sim all right but who's
gonna fly the ship come on how hard
could it be so I'll see you at Mexico
yep see you there
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys here's even more reactions to
what I just reviewed this week how do I
feel about the last Jedi now after
seeing it four times I love it I
absolutely love it Star Wars last Jedi
you went full prequel you never go full
prequel I was utterly disappointed with
Ferdinand but Star Wars was awesome
there were a lot of epic amazing things
there's those awesome like one column
twist there were just like disappointing
turnouts
all right the more that I think about it
I think that I'm 100% okay with House
Snoke was handled and raised parentage
but what did you guys think you want
your reaction to be in the next
nostalgia critic next week I'll be
reviewing Mars Attacks just download the
Stardust app at the link below follow us
at nostalgia critic record your reaction
and then tweet it to us with this
hashtag or use Facebook the ones we like
best will make it in the next nostalgia
critic video we absolutely love going
through and seeing everybody's different
reactions the over-the-top one's the
funny ones there's such a wide variety
out there and we love watching them and
you will too so download the app get out
there and show us your crazy reactions
[Music]
you
it feels so right
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out for those have been paying
attention we did a charity stream not
long ago for a st. Jude Children's
Hospital research and we're keeping that
video open and donations open for a
little bit if you go to our YouTube
channel you can see where the charity
streaming video is and we're still
having the donation link open for a few
more days so that's what the charity is
gonna be this week and if by the time
you see this it's you know gone maybe
you saw that sometime later still donate
it is a wonderful organization it's one
of those charities where you know how
you can't do research and certain things
and you find out stuff like you know oh
I didn't know that this is one of those
charities were the more research you do
just the cooler stuff you find and they
just do so much wonderful phenomenal
stuff and yeah it's just definitely
worth checking out and so definitely for
the charity stream that we did
definitely consider going over there and
donating and event the charity stream if
the link is gone by the time you watch
this please consider giving anyway
because they do such wonderful
phenomenal work definitely check it out
if you get a chance and thank you so
much
take care
you